los hongos pueden ser la clave para
limpiar las playas de argentina en el
país de 9 millones de fumadores una sola
colilla puede contaminar hasta 40 litros
de agua para reciclar este material
altamente tóxico científicos de buenos
aires- viajaron hasta la selva misionera
del litoral argentino donde se encuentra
esta especie de hongos nosotros las
aislamos y las trajimos al laboratorio
para tratar con eso y nosotros generamos
un
como si fuera un pre proceso digamos
para detoxificador el material y después
lo que queda que sería el filtro de
acetato eso hay muchos lugares que ya
pueden reutilizarlos jonan con fisher ya
los científicos demostraron que los
hongos funcionan como sensores de
toxicidad alimentándose de las colillas
y de la humedad en un ecosistema
acuático esta línea de investigación es
un procedimiento sencillo y barato ya
que los científicos también se ven
afectados por la inestabilidad económica
en argentina contamos con varias fuentes
de financiamiento pero todas las fuentes
son bastante escasas en relación a las
fuentes de financiamiento que con las
que cuentan grupos de investigación en
el primer mundo
el proyecto para limpiar los filtros de
cigarrillos con hongos de pudrición
blanca lleva siete años de estudio y ya
he conseguido desintoxicar las colillas
una vez que se publiquen las pruebas y
los resultados finales la investigación
pasará a una planta piloto que llevará
la tecnología de reciclaje ambiental al
plano industrial